wir stehen jetzt hier einem Leopard 1
Panzer hier ausgestellt quasi als
Museumsstück inwieweit kann denn ein
Leopard 1 der Ukraine noch nützlich sein
der Leopard 1 hier in der Version A5
zeigt dass das Panzer bei uns 203 mal
mit diesem Kampfpanzer ausgestattet war
der Leopard 1 würde ihn
als
alt
älter aber nicht veraltet bezeichnen er
wurde zwar beginnen in den 60er Jahren
hergestellt aber die Kraftwert steigen
also die Verbesserungen die wir hier
beim Leopard 1,5 also bei dieser Version
haben die wurden Mitte Ende der 80er in
die Gruppe eingeführt und
mit dem Leopard 1 A5 wurden die
Fähigkeiten dieses Leopard 1
insbesondere mit Blick auf die
Feuerleitanlage denen des Leopard 2 A4
angeglichen also auf den Stand Leopard 2
A4 gebracht die sind die da quasi recht
ähnlich sozusagen auf der Ebene die
sichtsysteme angeht und die Fähigkeit
vor allem aus der Fahrt zu treffen sind
sich Leopard 1,5 und Leopard 2 A4 sehr
ähnlich natürlich ist die Feuerkraft
aufgrund der 105 mm Kanone etwas kleiner
auch das Schutzniveau mit Blick auf die
Panzerung etwas geringer als beim
Leopard 2 A4 aber mit Blick auf
Mobilität
die Fähigkeit sehr präzise aus der Fahrt
zu schießen
ist ja immer noch ein sehr guter
Kampfpanzer der es mit den älteren
T-Modellen russischer Bauart ich sag mal
bis zum T-72 aufnehmen kann und
dementsprechend für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte von Nutzen sein kann wie
ist es denn für die Ukraine möglich so
ein Leopard 1 Kampfpanzer noch zu
beschaffen
also bei der Bundeswehr ist der Leopard
1 auch die Variante 1 A5 nicht mehr im
Betrieb das heißt wir stehen hier vor
einem traditionspanzer einem
Museumsstück der auch die militarisiert
ist das heißt die Hydraulikflüssigkeit
sind abgelassen
die Waffe wurde die militarisiert so
dass er nicht mehr einsetzbar ist
einsatzbereite oder einsatzbereit
Machbare Leopard 1,5 sind die man hört
doch bei der Industrie verfügbar und
dort würden dann diese auch herkommen
müssen